sensible deuxième thème sur lequel nous
voudrions revenir maintenant celui de la
justice et des médias ou à tout le moins
la nécessité pour les hommes et les
femmes de justice de trouver un langage
plus moderne plus direct pour expliquer
leur démarche et pour s'adapter à des
conditions nouvelles créées par le
développement des médias les médias qui
influent sur le comportement des hommes
qui font office de tribunal de
substitution et quelquefois de forums
isabelle bechler thierry meignanne
thévenin envoyés spéciaux à lépanges sur
vologne pour l' affaire grégory ont
voulu profiter
là-bas de la présence de nombreux
journalistes sur place pour vous faire
découvrir leurs réactions
quant aux propos du garde des sceaux sur
le thème justice et médias se mobilisent
nous avons retenu trois idées forces
dans l'intervention du garde des sceaux
hier soir préserver le secret de
l'instruction
apprendre aux magistrats à contrôler les
rumeurs et retrouver si c'est possible
la sérénité nécessaire à la justice dans
une affaire aussi tragique
il y a quinze jours de cela le procureur
général a diffusé un communiqué dans
lequel il ne disait rien d'autre que
ceux ci nous sommes tournant d'une
affaire très difficile avec les
résonances humaine très profonde
je demande 15 à toute la phase de
concilier la liberté d'information qui
doit être absolument respectée avec
toutes les réserves possibles
après les personnes dans des
circonstances bien sûr si il y avait une
information plus constante et plus
choisi de la part des autorités
judiciaires
il y aurait eu moins de risques de
dérapages et des rapports moins
anarchique entre la justice et
journalistes la justice peut-être en
dépit de ce que dit mme badinter doit
s'interroger sur son rôle dans cette
affaire
dans une affaire qui est beaucoup plus
complexe beaucoup plus difficile que
sans doute les enquêteurs ne l'ont cru
au départ et je pense que la presse elle
même doit s'interroger
malgré tout par rapport à la rumeur
parce que nous ne sommes pas que miroir
de cette rumeur
nous participons à l'élaboration de la
rumeur
et d'un point de vue déontologique je
pense quand même que cette affaire nous
pose beaucoup de problèmes humour
nous avons été utilisé par dit que dans
différents intervenants de l'enquète on
a été utilisé par rapport à ces rumeurs
se dire qu'on a on s'est servi un petit
peu de la presse comme de relais pour
lancer dans la dans la nature des
rumeurs est ce qu'il le faisait savait
que ces rumeurs allaient faire mal la
rumeur a poussé jean marie ou si jean
marie villemin a tué veut dire il y à il
ya quelques jours avant que l'on mette
en cause
sa femme la rumeur mettant costa femmes
dans la presse j'en arrive il n'avait
pas du tout le même comportement qu'il a
eu et un crescendo
j'ai l'impression que dans cette affaire
il y avait été des profils mais andy
laroche et des eaux
j'ai l'impression j'en suis même
quasiment persuadé on est d aider pro
laroche antilles et non sur ça c'est un
an le temps je pense aussi qu'un
journaliste a le droit de penser ce
qu'il veut sur une affaire et d'aller
créer ou de le dire
composé à la rumeur la précision du cul
la rue et c'est le communiqué que j'aime
et éditeurs pour préserver le secret de
l'instruction de garde des sceaux
proposé qu'à l'avenir le procureur de la
république joue un rôle d'attaché de
presse du palais de justice et cela n'a
pas convaincu les journalistes présence
d'une instruction c zéro 6 nuls ça
n'existe plus en france fin une
réflexion aussi pour la justice par
rapport au secret de l'instruction où
les magistrats eux-mêmes ne semble pas
tellement satisfait de la situation de
légal qui existe à l'heure actuelle
autour toujours confiance dans la
justice ça cela est aux commandes de
l'as roma et vous savez c'est cette
demande que je fais à cet instant que la
justice soit laissée à elle-même qu'elle
façonne akwasi je ne sais pas ce que
c'est que la sérénité
c'est quoi ça va être en accord avec sa
conscience c'est le christ et du calme
c'est c'est éteindre toutes les passions
c'est ça la sérénité en tout cas au
niveau au niveau de grégory s'est fait
largement compromis
c'est l'histoire de toute évidence et
rapportera justice demeureront
difficiles sinon conflictuelle car les
magistrats comme les journalistes sont
des hommes qui ont chacun leur passion
et leurs faiblesses
il faut souhaiter que la commission fera
justice puisse élaborer des règles de
bon voisinage les dérapages de la sphère
grégory auront du moins permis de poser
ses questions